Go into a room with a mirror.
Turn off all the lights.
Light a candle, look into the mirror, and start chanting "Bloody Mary."
Say this spooky phrase thirteen times,...
...and the image of Bloody Mary will appear in the mirror!
She will be standing behind you, over your left shoulder!
But beware: Bloody Mary has surprises waiting for those who call her.
She sometimes kills the caller.
Other times, she scratches out his or her eyes.
She can drive the person crazy.
Sometimes, she grabs people and pulls them into the mirror with her!
The urban legend of Bloody Mary has been around for generations.
School kids all around the world have entered dark bathrooms to try this game.
Many run away in fright as they say "Bloody Mary" for the thirteenth time.
In 1978, folklorist Janet Langlois became interested in the legend.
At that time, the legend was already widespread around the United States.
Langlois visited a Catholic girls' school and interviewed eighty students.
She compared their stories and determined that the story of Bloody Mary...
...might come from an old legend about the crying ghost of a woman...
...who eternally searches for her murdered children.
However, no one really knows who Mary may have been.
The Bloody Mary legend is renewed with each generation of daring adolescents.
Generations from now,...
...school children will probably still be scaring themselves with this timeless, terrifying legend.